the Don sores banasura move Ephraim
trecek Clark oh hey guys I'm Ryan right
hey guys I'm salamander Sally so I'm
kind of been binge-watching cinemasins I
do that like I I tend to stay away from
a channel not intentional and then I'll
go back and I'm like I gotta catch up on
anything I've ever missed I'm so guilty
of that unlike 3:00 in the morning I
really just have no time to do it is
yeah and if you guys are Noah cinemasins
are you're about to find out
they're one of my favorite channels
hands down oh yeah it's everything wrong
with Jurassic Park which is my favorite
movie
yeah yeah I love Jurassic Park I'm
interested to see what they have to say
about what's wrong with it I don't know
it's just gonna be funny stuff or like
I'm gonna sit here and go I hope is to
follow me so that I don't not like the
movie yeah that's the one scary thing is
sometimes you'll really like a film and
then you'll watch this and you're like I
never realized so many problems this
movie had yeah like Percy Jackson man
don't always agree but you know let's
find out
that's our look very scary there is no
way in hell this kid could see on TV
screen from this angle and for behind
all these kingdoms denim pants together
even if it's period-accurate it's still
assist but they kept dinosaur meat I
want to know how John Hammond gets from
the helicopter to the trailer without
one person seeing it I own an iron I've
leased it I got them so do you own it or
do you lease it space aliens stole my
thing exactly the kind of article I
would expect archaeologists and
paleontologists to hang on the bridge
despite how carefully Audrina is holding
his bag full of ember you're mine
someone steals it without him noticing
calculator watch during flight we see a
mad aceton next to the window and the
helicopter is obviously moving in this
direction meaning Hamid is on the
aircraft's left side but then when it
lands Hamid is now sitting all the way
over by the other window on the right
side these jeeps are just now backing up
but in the overhead shot where the
helicopter was landing they were already
in place so wait the real John Hammond
is planning to stand here once the park
opens all day every day oh he's going to
tell you but he won't offer any
explanation for how they got the DNA to
recreate the extinct plants like the one
you saw in the Jeep the robot arms
holding the hatching egg good place
completely disappeared from one shot to
the next kind of control you're
attempting is it's not possible calm
down Malcolm I'm sure nothing could
possibly go wrong
bread crafts they told you they had a
t-rex here a Raptors really that biggest
surprise stood on the shoulders of
geniuses to accomplish something it's
almost like he's talking about synthesis
no one touches their lunch and they all
need for the tour without anything dress
apart to evoke quaterly by putting the
t-rex paddock on the second stop of the
tool any self-respecting a clerk would
know to put the t-rex last any better
stay here Ellie just lets this little
keep run into what she thinks is a
possibly dangerous situation okay so the
trike to meet the lilacs and Ellie
couldn't find any lilacs and the trick
but this the movie still saying they ate
the lilacs does anybody care about the
fate of the strike in this movie no okay
man this company engine is really awful
they don't even spell Tyrannosaurus or
Stegosaurus right actually in poker he's
not typing the command CD speaking ah
doesn't understand a singer happy track
instead of amusing the same track to
return these you have all your tour cars
going in opposite directions at the same
time or the same tracks well
got one thing right people can use the
glass as a field in case of a t-rex
effect earlier we saw the t-rex standing
next to this fence and then suddenly
there's a huge clip that is way deeper
than a t-rex is tall awesome shot but
the direction closer to the Jeep ranch
in Steven Spielberg cannot resist
illumiroom pants not badly jumps over
the same log twice dr. grant how do you
expect to continue if he jumps when
you're standing so far ah so the fence
turns sharply to the right in this show
but then turns to the left in the next
shot and that's assuming you needed to
climb the fence in the first place
considering that it appears to end it
just one section away from where you
chose to comment but this fence even
shot castings not grounded at all this
game warden waits until the last
possible moment to make his weapon fully
ready to fire this Raptor is looking
directly where the kids are and somehow
doesn't seem oh you can move you're on
the wrong at the door be holding much
anyway let's reboot the system using
some kind of flight simulator
that is one big plant [ __ ] I don't think
that's the only something that doesn't
deter me away yeah it's still like
something whether it is a flaw it's
mainly just continuity it's merely
continuity which every movie has I mean
usually no it's just when it comes to
filming like that's the whole point of
editing your screen to not notice it
like I didn't notice a lot of what they
said because it's there it's evident
when they're pointing it out but almond
gross and everything else that's working
that I don't notice yeah that like
something like that it cuz mine yeah
it's mainly just like set issues like
they just didn't double-check which you
know when you're filming you can't film
every scene the same scene like the same
day sometimes it's just like split up so
it's hard to get it right mm-hmm cuz
yeah I'd still make they didn't really
talk about the story being [ __ ] up it
was like stuff like Oh Samuel Jackson
he's saying something but he's not
typing what he's saying or yeah it's
just like little continuity stuff and
then some stuff is a little convenient
like yeah when the glass breaks through
and the kids are there like it's a
famous moment but it still is like a lot
of movies can't be too realistic girl to
stop fun like if you make things too
realistic there's what story is there
they would have died the first time do
you agree yeah you know but that's what
makes it fun and there are some things
that do get you thinking like flaws that
will kind of throw me off like when the
t-rex appears for the first time but
then they look over the bridge I
remember seeing that movie I was like
how did that get there where was it and
then I remember when they were all
sitting down eating but they none of
them ate anything they just got up I was
like but I wanted to eat that food and
then when he was you know doing the back
and forth I was like how are they gonna
do that if it's a real theme parks true
those sort of things I did notice it
didn't distract me enough to not like
the movie absolutely yeah no these are
all minor things that I'm nothing to do
with the actual plot telling or
storytelling of the film it's still fun
that's what I mean the show can still be
fun yeah because you're still like oh
would I never noticed that honestly no
like mad props to them though because I
never would have sat through that movie
long enough just to find those little
errors like that I'm already oh yeah
that's hard so that's I was like whoa
how did they know that it was I don't
know it was cool like the one when he
was on the fence that one like threw me
off so much I was like whoa over there
right that is a really big flaw in it no
they're very [ __ ] clever them an
honest trailer is very clever anyway
guys yeah thanks for sitting here with
us if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects and you
can check out salamander Sally's channel
where she does a lot of vlogs and skits
it's really fun it's really fun stuff
time you'll have fun look at her ever no
last cow Alaska the Lascaux hi I like to
play guitar and yeah I love spider-man
too my second favorite is Batman me too
my first favorite that's about it oh and
I also have a youtube channel he did not
tell us for YouTube channel he having a
girl it's a girl it's a guy with long
hair good for you I like guys in long
hair GD looks like this guy I once knew
named Jessie I was totally into this
chick and then this guy just shows up
out of nowhere
I knew him it was me he bumped into and
then they became boyfriend and
girlfriend that's messed up yeah [ __ ]
Jessie if you're anything like him
because you look like him then no no
don't be stealing people's girlfriends
now that's not very that's not nice not
nice I like my girlfriend she's hot
she's sexy she's beautiful on the inside
and the outside yeah man I will not talk
perverted things about her even though
she gets me really hard it will not say
anything
well what does it matter because then if
you never would have taken that girl
away you never would've ended up a
Veronica I know I'm talking about
Oh
these guys must be high right yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ]
do you did you eat the rest of me right
now I did not eat the rest of my well
yeah I didn't eat the rest of my intern
oh wait yeah I did